okay
thank you very much
um i'm really honored to be um be here
today and we have a list of great
speakers throughout the day
but you know to be honest
with you probably the main reason i'm
here today is the fact that i work right
next to phantom for a year and a half
so you know when you when you have a
colleague who's really hardworking and
productive be really nice to them
because they may actually invite you for
talk someday
but you should also be nice to people
who aren't as productive too that's
really a nice
thing yeah
so alice gave a great introduction to
single cell analysis and single cell
rna-seq and i was recently at the ni
single cell meeting uh uh just a couple
weeks ago and it's clear that clear that
there has been a great
uh uh
significant amount of progress towards
single site analysis both in transcripts
and uh proteome
but right now the sense i get is like
much of the analysis really limited to
just several hundred to you know several
thousands of single cells now this
really isn't a problem is there a laser
pointer
okay and this really isn't a problem if
you're starting a small number of cells
in
for linear tracing or so in simple model
organisms such as the elegance but for
many other problems such as tumor cell
heterogeneity and mammalian organisms or
if you're interested in unbiased cell
type classification uh let's say human
adult brain that contains up to uh over
100 billion cells
this could be a current throughput it
really isn't adequate
so
next
okay so
over the last two years uh we've had
uh we've taken some you know big steps
towards uh
this goal of trying to understand
um single cell biology in the
organizable level uh and now we have a
fairly modestly high throughput method
of analyzing multiple single cell
transcriptome uh
using some of the methods that alice
talked about earlier
now these methods generally use
one methods that
dissociate the tissue and then using
either micromanipulation or fat sorting
or
flu dimes new technology of using
microfluidics to compartment
compartmentalize various rna
amplification methods and for rna seed
and recently jim eberline from penn
published a really nice study uh using
um
a photo act photo activatable decaging
of rna capture probes inside two and
when they can shine their a laser on
either single cells or a sub
sub-cellular compartmental region
compartmental region that can actually
capture a regionalized rna and they can
amplify that and
do rnac so our method here physique
this is something i'm going to talk
about
for the rest of my talk
so
all these methods are great the main
thing is that you know here a this and
now i'll talk about how we can scale
this up to you know over 10 thousands of
cells but still 10 000 is relatively
small compared to billions of cells that
we have in the brain
and this uh
this acronym for this method is called
tiva
and this way a photo activate
activated laser capture meth
capture method is great but it's
probably not as scalable as uh
we would like
so
and by the way all these methods really
failed to capture the spatial context of
gene expression
so why is why should we care about
spatial expression
spatial context well we are interested
in really understanding the cellular
phenotype at an individual level but
if we don't actually care about the
spatial context that's like you know
human geneticists saying that i only
study genes i don't care about the land
or the history i mean you really have to
understand the geography the climate
natural resources these people are under
because and genetics is a function of
natural selection the cells are exactly
the same way too so in a you're seeing a
diagram of uh tumor cell evolution right
so it's not just a stochastic process
cells actually they talk to one another
they sometimes inhibit or promote each
other's growth sometimes they
so they compete with one another and
they sometimes cooperate
now this behavior can be see whether
you're looking at a microorganism or
amphibians and the you know understand
the landscape is absolutely important
for understanding individual phenotype
and this is probably the same uh and
with neurons or any any other
developmental systems as well
so
how do we actually do this for things
like transcriptome analysis now
transcript is important because it's one
of the
most fundamental ways for genetic
information to get out there outside the
genome right
so as you know
fish or fluorescent inside hybridization
is the gold standard in terms of
sensitivity and depending on the method
also specificity and
but
um you know they're notoriously low
throughput and they're having a lot of
efforts to multiplex uh fish or rna
localization in single cells so it
really started you know back in the
early 2001 from robert singer's lab who
really pioneered this field so he used
multiple color color localization bar
coding to
do profiling of small number of genes
and more recently from langkai's lab at
caltech he came up with a color
transition uh
barcoding or
fish sequencing in which he used
supervision microscopy combined with
sequential hybridization stripping
hybridization stripping to understand
the identity of the
transcripts
but
other methods you really are limited to
maybe a few dozens or
maybe a hundred transcripts not even
close to
thousands of genes that are cell may
express
and the
even even beyond that
uh
these methods are perhaps almost too
sensitive so meaning that if you are
looking at a really abundant genes you
there's a physical factor of optical
diffraction limit where you just cannot
get the accurate uh quantitative
quantitative measurement of gene
expression and that's a key example is
gap d h i mean if you see a slide of gap
d a single cell transcript you just
can't count them and imagine doing that
for a thousand other transcripts
so
now
i can't go into all the limitations of
fish in this talk but and there are
these and other problems with fresh and
other targeted sequencing methods or
detection methods so we really decided
to start from scratch and think that you
know fundamentals of the whole approach
so
after two to three years of kind of
struggling with this issue and trying to
figure out what the true bottlenecks
were
i really found to solve you know not
just rna-seq or iron detection method
but really just a fundamental key
problems in all
self-imaging period which is how do you
count objects
within your image i mean you have
background fluorescence you have you
know
objects of different sizes and how do
you even multiplex them so
the some of the things that i focus on
for the next uh several years are okay
let's definitely do an unbiased whole
transcriptome sampling number two now
i'm interested in not just single cells
but a wide area because most development
biologists you know you want to study
the lamb or the head or some large
structures with a spatial pattern right
so i don't want to be doing just you
know a supervision microscopy so how do
we actually do white fuel resolution uh
imaging while still being able to count
individual molecules so that was really
important and third
now
regardless of what you use for actual
imaging ultimately you all have the
upper limit of what you can count
discretely so how do we actually is
there a method for a registering
independent molecular quantification all
this means is that if you can sequence
it then you can have a quantitative
sequencing data
so
the big breakthrough came in
2010 when we were able to generate a
matrix of cdna molecules inside to
within cells and tissues that are super
bright so it was compatible with any
kind of 3d or 2d imaging and that
process really involved first reverse
fixing your cells and reverse
transcribing transcribing your rna in
situ and then you we we add the uh this
amino aloe dp to add amine backbone to
your cdna molecules so they can be
irreversibly cross-linked to your
protein matrix we circularize it and has
a little adapter so you can use this for
rca for only circular amplification and
during rolling circle amplification you
also add immunology utp so now your cdna
applicant has all these kind of
lysine like backbone right so you cannot
crosslink it so after you crosslink it
with this molecule it becomes a
transparent hydrogel that's you can boil
it dry it you can do anything
to it and it stays you know
stable and which means that you can
actually sequence for a very long time
so the key thing is that you know uh
this is a random hexamer uh if you
do this method with a random hexamer but
do not add uh rt enzyme you don't get
any amplification it's this is just too
short to circularize but if you do have
an
uh
reverse transcriptase then you get an
efficient application of the
original template meaning that whatever
you sequence is it has a c dna sequence
in it
so
if this is uh the amplicon uh uh uh use
uh generating solution
viewed using tem we've also repeated
this experiment with supervision
microscopy
and on average these things are about
200 nanometers in diameter and also they
contain about 1000 copies of the
original cdna
template meaning that compared to a
single molecule detection method or a
single molecule rna fish which can use
up to 20 floor force per molecule we're
about you know 50 times even 100 times
brighter than those molecules this is
why we can actually do all kinds of 3d
imaging at a molecular resolution so
this just shows you the improvement in
our optical characteristics and which
enables all kinds of microscopy
and this also shows you that we can
cycle this if we can hybridize and strip
and hybridize and strip for many many
cycles and uh we can still retain you
know really high uh great uh signal to
noise ratio the value actually goes up
because you know we did this manually
and by the time you get to a 60 cycle
you actually get really good so yeah so
so this is an example of our
rna-seq library inside
generation in ips cells so using
confocal microscopy you can see that you
can see have nuclear nucleolus here you
have
you can actually see you know
nuclear membrane
uh you can see cytoplanic vesicles here
is an example of nuclear membrane
nuclear speckles this is a condensing
chromatin there's a metaphase chromatin
suggesting that once you have an
amplicon even despite the fact that you
are doing all these washes they are not
just freely floating around and they are
retaining their original
spatial distribution
so we can do this in ips cells uh
fireblast a must uh um this is an ffpe
section so mouse embryo section brain
section from the island brain institute
this is a homo drosophila embryo almost
any sample and we i haven't shown uh
uh bringing organoids and several other
samples almost any sample that we uh we
looked at our method seems to work
so this is a
movie of
z stack going through an ips cell so you
can see the uh nuclear membrane
nucleolus so and new apparent nuclear
speckles this is a very important thing
i want you to remember because there are
some errors in the cell that we know are
full of rna that our method just cannot
penetrate it's probably because they're
very tightly crosslinked but you'll see
later that this actually helps us to
eliminate things that the kinds of rna
that we actually don't want in our data
set
so this is a this is a
nucleolus there are about 100 amplicons
in the nucleolus in ips cells
so uh
so serial quantitation beyond microscopy
resolution so how do we achieve this so
this is actually the first problem i
solved like three four years ago which
is that
you know sequencing lets you to almost
titrate the object density that you're
gonna
count
how do i do how do you do that that is
because and you can use a sequencing
primer that uh extends by one and
this these are just random uh sequences
here so what uh what you have then is
you actually are sequencing you know all
the molecules that's present
but then if you then strip that and
extend the sequencing primer by one and
you're detecting one-fourth of the
density that's present here you extend
it by another
that's 1 16 of the original density here
so if you keep doing this you can
actually make a serial titration curve
from the images that you have so even if
at this point you can't individually
count objects accurately you can
extrapolate
the molecular quantities for every
single gene that you have
and another point that we made in our
paper which was recently published in
science that
normal way of counting objects you have
to depend on intensity based image
processing meaning that you set to set
your threshold based on known and uh
known and your experiment specific
signature noise ratio but in our case we
don't have an intensity threshold we
just call sequences from every single
pixel no matter how dim they are and the
probability of them um actually being a
false positive is just purely related to
how long your sequencing views are so we
have a way so
so by eliminating all kinds of intensity
filter we can identify objects purely
based on this
sequence information and once we do that
we actually group related sequences into
an object so that's a this is a
different way of doing image analysis
and in the future we think this is going
to have a really big impact on how
images are processed if you can tag your
objects with sequence
so we're currently we just submitted a
protocol uh paper and it should be
hopefully it'll come out within the next
month or two
so our protocol a lot of people think
this is a really hard protocol but i
think other rna technologies are tougher
except that
they have automation and we don't and we
think we're going to solve that very
soon
so
this the rna-seq method the library
construction method takes two days and
this sequencing uh takes about 10 to 15
days
this is the hard part without automation
the actual image processing and
base calling and data analysis takes one
to three days so it's not that bad
so i just quick note about solid
sequencing we use solid sequencing
instead of illumina only because solid
sequencing lets you
uh to do this at room temperature so we
have our sample sitting in the
microscope right we're changing all this
fluid and we just didn't want to build
uh the
flow cell around the microscope at 70
degrees so that's the primary reason for
us uh
using this and also the fact that solid
sequencing chemistry you can just buy
off the shelf but uh we know that so
illumina and i and both live
technologies and illumina are actually
working with us right now and um
illumina chemistry works just fine
and the first demonstration of
our method was shown by reza keller
another postdoc in our lab he did
essentially targeted the five prime end
of the m cherry uh transcript and he
showed that uh we can actually sequence
the five prime end of a transcript sort
of like five prime paste uh method
and you know uh if you add doxycycline
uh this is a cyclin-inducible transcript
so it comes up nicely and then if you
map where their transcripts lie you uh
vast about 50
if 98 mapped to the sense strand of that
m cherry and over 55 mapped to the
within uh two base uh resolution of the
transcript star site
so evan dory uh he's a graduate student
in our lab he did bulk of the you know
all the you know sequencing and
base calling and writing all the
softwares so what he did is uh
just to remind a little bit so
so in order to do this manually so you
need a dedicated confocal microscope
that you just nobody can touch for two
weeks and we had a really tough time uh
finding it and we did finally we finally
found it and we're incredibly happy only
to find out if the stage was broken so
we had an option of okay do we wait till
the stages get it gets fixed or do we
just you know sequence this one field of
view and we
you know it was tough it was a bit
appeal to swallow but we just focus on
just one field of view so this is from
the experiment so you do fibrous imaging
and you do 30 cycles of sequencing and
you align all those images and then uh
using the uh and then for each pixel you
align you you use bow tie and then you
map it to the reference sequence
reference library and then you know you
cluster those pixels into groups of
objects right and then you say okay what
are these objects so vast majority over
95 percent mapped to the sense strand so
that's good
and about 43 percent uh were uh
43 were ribosomal rna which was lower
than what we expected but that actually
enabled us to get a lot of mrna reads
so
what we were really surprised is that if
you just we got about 2 2000 genes from
that experiment and then if you just
take the top 100
genes and just look at it even you don't
even have to do a term analysis what we
found is like all of them were the
fibroblast markers identified over the
past five decades just doing exp using
various different types of experiments
and if you can take you know top 50
genes hundred genes or a thousand genes
didn't matter how wet grooms you pick
they
just fall into collagen
ossification bone skin developmental
processes uh without doing any other
bioinformatics now when you compare this
to rna-seq
over genes that are observed more than
five to ten times uh you have a
correlation that's as good as you know
0.69 with fibroblasts but with other
cell types the quarter is much lower
meaning that we really are detecting
something that's functionally
significant
and for every one of our pixels and
object we have an x y coordinate right
so we can actually have here's an image
and this looks like a nucleus and this
looks like a cytoplasm we actually
generate an image mask right and we say
okay for every read what is the relative
enrichment in different cellular
compartments and what we see that is a
mrna
this is out of uh four thousand um uh
genes
out of uh four thousand four thousand
genes we're able to do this analysis
about 200 genes uh for these guys uh
their mrna and mitochondrial ribosomal
rna which is in the cytoplasm and
non-coding rna and other types of small
rna molecules that are in the nucleus
such as mallet 1 and need 1.
for a very abundant genes with lot of
weeds with 1.x5 coverage
we can actually uh detect uh physically
uh uh physiologically relevant uh
transcendental transcription splicing uh
events
so i just wanna drive this uh home uh uh
drive this point home is that
we compare this to 27 million views of
illumina are in secrece from the same
cell line
and you know
this is what you expect to see
housekeeping genes and things are
involved in just general general cell
functions and
protein and rna processing this is why
you have to do you know principle
component analysis or relative full
enrichment
bioinformatics
but
if you were to take our data set and we
only have 15 000 wreaths and we can take
either you know top 100 500 or 1000
genes in this table i use thousand genes
but immediately all the things that you
associate with uh
fibroblasts they pop up right to the top
so this told us like hey you know we
don't we might be able to actually
really get after the cell function just
by doing using our technology without
having to worry about um you know what
is our you know goal standard negative
and positive controls and such so
again you know we are also limited by
the fact that we couldn't really
uh scan a large area so we just came up
with a very simple uh you know a
solution where
we just grow the cell and make a scratch
and let the cells kind of crawl in and
we just say okay can we detect cells
that are migrating in versus cells that
are static right at least there should
be some difference in cell cycle maybe
or something right
so
when we did that uh we did this for
about five fields of view
and you can clearly see that there are
some morphological differences so that
was good so and this experiment was done
in the presence of egf to mimic you know
the environment or the military present
in actual wound healing right so as soon
as we added egf what we found is that
ribosomal rna
made up 80 of the transcriptome now all
the mrna they seem more or less you know
stable but
non-coding rna such as a ribosomal rna
they they just like jump right up and
this also suggests that using ribosomal
rna as your relative gene expression
control may not be such a great idea
so again because we could our these are
very informative we can compare that
with egf all the things that you
associate with a fibroblast they go down
things that you associate with cell
migration with egf they come up
so we again just like nuclear to
cytoplasmic
ratio analysis we can actually create a
mask for different regions of the dish
so these are all the
reeds obtained from the regions
associated with cell migration all the
reefs associated with contact inhibitors
phenotypes and then now these plots are
uh noise
noisier than they actually are because
we use jitter plot to avoid um over
plotting so what you see is that overall
the correlation between
this region and this region is about
eight three
now one thing that i didn't show you the
one slide that i skipped is that
now we're growing the cell
all simultaneously from the same batch
we change the media the same day right
we fix it the same way and we sequenced
it we put you do everything exactly the
same right so the technical noise or
technical variation from region to
region is according to like
0.9999 because essentially these are the
same field right so if you're trying to
take minor biological differences
between two regions of the dish
we can really our method is really
sensitive
so uh if you do this and there are about
12 genes that actually meet our
arbitrarily defined threshold for what
significant
significance
so one is really obvious the others are
kind of on the borderline but if you
look at these 12 genes
three are uh related to collagen but all
uh eight of um
eight of them are
involved in actin
um
extracellular matrix receptor dynamics
they include gi d4 prp f40 um and
wink one so
we don't think that this is uh this is
an accident so uh we think that you know
physique is able to identify genius gene
novo even so if you were to try to
design fetch probes you would never have
targeted visions because these genes are
relatively fairly unknown
uncharacterized in the field of cell
migration second uh
so this means that you know we can
actually detect pathways the nova and
discover unexpected players in
players that are biologically important
so i just want to show you a couple
movies
so this is a time series of uh
sequencing reaction you can just focus
on one dot here
or this dot
so you have to you know you have to
realize that this is done over two weeks
manually right in a room that's about 42
degrees hot because there is no
ventilation right so our sample is
incredibly robust and stable right
and this
is a view where
the z-axis actually times so you're
actually seeing 30 cycles of basis so
this bar represents a sequence barcode
so you're seeing a single cell with
about 300 barcodes we've gotten up to
about a thousand barcodes without a
problem
but for this experiment you know we
weren't quite sure how well they would
align for the paper so we actually lower
the density a little bit
so you can almost think of this as a
virtual nanostring technology that's the
nova
so
what are current priorities well
this whole process
for each uh each tile took us for 30 to
40 minutes right so we're switching over
to uh spinning this 3d microscopy and
we're seeing dramatic improvements of
imaging speed
so
using spinning spinning desks we think
so we recently wrote a grant with tony
zedor and ed boyden
we our aim is to
sequence a hundred and then thousand
brain sections um
first and second year and with this uh
gain speed we think that's totally
doable
uh we also
are about two to three weeks away from
fully automating this and
uh the area that we can tile is probably
gonna be greater than a thousand fold
from our original experiment so combined
our goal in the next two to three months
is to really have a brain section or
sections with over more than 10 million
reads per section
so
in our um paper we didn't we did not
deplete ribosomal rna because we
actually want to use ribosomal reads as
a control i mean how i mean
see because they're so abundant we can
use that to estimate base calling
accuracy and bias and all of that but
our next goal is to deplete ribosomal
rna that should increase our uh per cell
rna account from two to uh two to five
full that's gonna actually allow us to
get closer to single cell this
functional discrimination
so
we're really excited with all these
collaborations they're super uh all
these are super excited collaborators
in fact recently
i started a twitter account um for the
first time i don't know how that works
but i have four followers my uh wife my
sister ed boyden i don't know why
and uh illumina and
illumina just actually presented
our work
to the sequencing technology
uh conference meaning that i think
they're pretty serious
oh i should mention that you know high
sick 2000 is actually a spinning disc
right that's fixed to just two planes
right
with automated tire scanning that's all
it is i mean it's not magic it's
oh and what i just told you is
i'm describing you how high high-steep
works so all we have to do is for all of
you guys to tweet them and say we need
the machine tomorrow and then i think
they're gonna
be convinced that there's a need in the
community
so so again you know with tony sodor and
boyden um uh we're doing uh a massive
parallel neuron segments uh uh neuron
cell type segmentation and transcriptome
profiling in situ experiments so reza
calhoun just did a around
a 33 round of sequencing reaction on a
brain
tissue slice and it looks fantastic and
hopefully he'll get his paper wrapped up
very soon
other things that include something i'm
working on is you have a self-priming
rna bar code that's expressed within the
nucleus
that gets carried over and binds to rna
by rna binding domain such as ms2 or
n-peptides from
p22 and other viruses and then you can
actually tag them uh individual
transmembrane proteins with a specific
rna bar code
and so this is something actively under
development
we're also
collaborating with pongin and other
groups to look really look at and also
jim eberlein
to really look at the distribution of
transcriptome along the dendrite and
exons uh with uh robert singer has
recently published a paper in science
showing that rna localizations and
neurons are dependent on long-term
potentiation this is this is something
we like to do transcript and white so
this uh this this is you're actually
seeing a bipolar neuron in vitro and the
red dots you're seeing is like
uh
amplicons present in all these neurons
and you can see that when you sequence
them they grow in four colors
so another thing i'm really excited
about is i'm also investigating um
wind signaling for cell polarity
in
epithelial cells in vivo and in vitro so
working with hyun from the vs institute
what we notice is that
all the epithelial cells that are grown
in the uh flat dash they just form one
layer but if you put them in on their
native setting which means that they
have the apical apical side where they
can diffuse their morphogens and the
basal cell where they can also diffuse
morphogenesis they actually form villi
and the case of intestinal epithelial
cells and in ips cells this is really
exciting is that they actually form
inner cell mass right directly on the
membrane
and we think that this extends to very
uh
and we've also shown that using
inhibitors of dk1 or event signaling we
know that these morphologists are
involved in these um in vitro uh
morphogenesis morphogenic phenomena well
what we like to do is really to
investigate
uh
uh transcriptome within this to see how
transcriptomically distributed on the
apical side and the basal side and this
is something that cannot you cannot do
with the current existing technology so
once she once you know things like you
know dkk one and one and nodal and
leftists they're all involved in
breaking symmetry now i think
understanding cell symmetry and how you
can actually break it by studying gene
expression at a level
at a transcription level so i i actually
think of this as you know chirality of
gene expression and which is the
ultimate kind of conceptualization of
what we can do with a single cell
resolution of you know spatial
information of the transcripts
so getting back to my uh earlier slide
so i have you know uh uh
projects that uh
uh that i'm starting to investigate uh
understanding tumor heterogeneity using
a mouse model of pancreatic
carcinoma and then
tracking it and trying to define its um
transcript and heterogeneity as well as
also to barcode them so that you can
actually
barcode them with either fluorophore or
actual rna expression barcode and
combine with you know a single cell rna
stick that alex talked about to really
understand how the micro environment
contribute to either inhibition or
promotion of certain cancer cell types
obviously if you were to combine this
with a mutation sql target mutation
sequencing as well as methylation
sequencing that'll be all the more
powerful
so i'm not going to get into this but i
will do i will say that you know you
know we came up with this technology not
because we are so excited about rna-seq
per se but we think there's a really uh
bottom leg in cell biology meaning that
you know next-gen sequencing is
discovering thousands of mutations every
day right anybody who does sequencing
they have molecular variants left and
right but we don't have the time to
actually test them functionally so how
do we test them so one thing that we
thought early on back in 2007 is that
if we can have a library of modifying
dna such as cast 9 library or shr
interlibrary or cdna library in fact the
library cells and then have them
undergo cell invasion or migration or
any other asset that you'd like to do
can we actually just sequence the
barcode and figure out which set of
genes are responsible for a set of you
know experimentally validated phenotype
so this is something that i like to
pursue over the next you know three four
years
and this is my final slide and this is
this is kind of uh food for thought
is that i told you about how
our genetically encoded rna binding
domain could be really hooked up to
almost anything you want right so you
could think about can your ligand or
synapsing or various other uh proteins
not only that
now you're going to hear about you know
genetically
quoted voltage and calcium indicators
right so if you had just you just a
picture in your uh mind if you had you
know all these blinking dots in live
tissue sections right they indicate the
activity of calcium level or something
right and then you record the
oscillations you fix the cells and then
you sequence the barcode associated with
each blink right and you say you think
oh all these blinking dots in this
region are they come they belong to a
same cell and with our bar code
30 bases
will encode 10 to the 18th different
cells uniquely
so you're not limited so you can
multiplex
as many cells that you want now all you
need is
time to scan so
all right so
this is my uh final slide so i'd like to
thank george
uh he
came up with the idea of you know
sequencing everything in situ back in
2003
uh he wanted to do uh insight to cell
sequencing for a long time
um but you know
yeah he first had to get the next
sequencing out of the way
and much of the work that you've seen
here is done by evan doherty he joined
the lab about a year ago or a year and a
half ago and really was absolutely
critical in closing uh
finishing getting our project to the
finish line
i'd like to also thank richard terry uh
he's been with the project for you know
over six years and he is very close to
getting the entire process automated
which be just phenomenal
um and i like to and also
allen brain institute and kunsan so
both of these uh people really helped us
early on just to think about you know
why why and where
we might use our technology for
okay thank you
so thanks for that let's take a couple
questions and then we'll break for lunch
yeah
do you have to modify the amount of
linker that you put in if you're going
to use alumina so you're switching from
ligation to synthesis is it affected at
all by the amount of crosstalking right
so
we've actually started playing with you
know reducing the amount of crosslinkers
um so we know that uh
you know if you are really going after
the single cell resolution where you
want to see the nuclear membrane really
nice nicely right then we kind of tend
to add more cross-linkers but that does
definitely inhibit our v length and also
our sensitivity right but if you're
interested in more of a kind of
population ecology right a mic tumor
cell environment where single cell
resolution isn't as important right then
we actually really back off the cross
linker and it looks like the protein
environment itself especially if you
refix it is enough to keep all the seeds
in place
okay another question
yeah jeff um
if transcripts are close to each other
yeah resolution becomes right an issue
right
and it closes not only x y but also
right and the neurons this is right so
you just explain that
sure
so our method is like a really slow
version of um supervision microscopy or
storm right where you know they use you
know steadcastic blinking of
subpopulation of um uh particles right
so we just exchange so you it's a very
simple you know rudimentary way of doing
what i showed earlier let's say instead
of one adapter sequence right let's say
you use 10 different adapter sequences
connected to random hexameter right that
means like if you just use one
sequencing primer you can subdivide your
uh library pool well into one tenth so
you get a much better spatial separation
and resolution
right so if you're to do then use
different sequencing primers right
combine the result you what
that's what so you have you know you're
counting every objects but each object
you are getting a much better uh
quantitative accuracy
and our method of just sliding the
primer does that much more in an elegant
way where you don't need all 10 you know
sequencing primers
all right okay so thank you so um let's
give it a big applause